- You are a mega mentor
on the voice this season.
Um, super stoked about that.
But I have to ask,
who is your favorite coach Ed?
(audience cheers)
I mean, who is it?
Just shout it out.
Just don't feel shy.
- No Kelly, only one person.
Only one person gave good gifts.
(Kelly laughs)
- It was, yeah.
- You are like, I can't say.
- It must have been you.
Because I, actually I
still have the jacket.
- You still see, I gave you presents.
- I still have the jacket in this house.
- I will buy your love Ed Sheeran.
I will do it.
Well, no, your daughter Lyra,
which is the most beautiful name ever.
She just turned one.
So how do you think,
we were talking about her
whenever you were visiting.
'Cause it was your first time away
from her for that amount of time.
So how do you think she's changed you?
- Well, I mean,
my bedtime has shifted from,
I'm no longer going to bed at five.
I'm getting up at four
or five, which is good.
But no,
I think there's like a different emotion
that has come through having a daughter.
And, man, she's just wonderful.
She's just wonderful.
She's just started walking.
She knows what her eyes and head
and mouth and blah, blah, blah.
And she's on the verge of talking
and just,
it's incredible to watch
all these things happen.